am i correct your nickname is hillbilly
kobe
that's what that's what they say
that's what they say okay
um
we could just end it there um but
what's the story behind that and
what is it like to
have been referred to as hillbilly kobe
for a while and to suddenly be here in
in this environment yeah so my my first
year at oklahoma we had a g.a his name
anthony rainey um he came up to me one
day and was like i figured it out and i
was like what do you what are you even
talking about and he was like hbk and i
was like what he was like hillbilly kobe
i was like
what whatever and then one of the
teammates heard it and it just stuck so
uh for for three years that's that's
what they said around i mean just
oklahoma and then i guess people caught
wind up elsewhere but i mean
it is what it is i just you know i just
moved forward from it
i'm fascinated by this hillbilly colby
thing are you more hillbilly or more
kobe
man i don't even know we'll go 50 50.
are you hillbilly uh not really but i'm
from i'm from arkansas the middle of
nowhere and i grew up on a farm so it's
uh it kind of fits
and you followed kobe when you were
growing up yes sir
all right
i'm done
appreciate y'all